So good morning.
I'm very,
very pleased to have Marlee Matlin here and I'm very pleased to introduce her
and have her come up here and tell us her story and,
and tell us about some of the causes that she's committed to.
Thank you.
Thank you Susan.
And speaking of not everyone knowing who I am,
it's true,
there isn't,
I don't know if any of you,
well I have to admit this,
but I was a huge,
I actually had a huge weakness,
uh,
when I have the time to watch a little television because I have four kids and
it's difficult to watch and I have one teenage girl was 14 and she's a huge fan
of the bachelor.
Okay.
You all know they show the bachelor and it just so happened that on dancing with
the stars when I was there,
I happened to meet the,
what's his name?
Jake.
Oh,
actually met Vienna.
Who is the woman who grabbed Jake or who Jake chose on this years of bachelor.
And she came up to me and she said,
are you an actress?
And of course clearly it proves that not everybody knows who I am.
Anyway,
I am so happy to be here today at the coolest place,
the Mecca of the Internet world.
Google.
Google is a sign.
What's the sign for Google?
This is the same Google headquarters.
It's like that moment when Darth Vader says,
Luke,
I am your father.
And everyone gasped and said,
no way.
I can't believe it's happening.
It's the ultimate cool to be here today.
And there's free food too.
I mean you guys have free red bull,
you have free food.
I can't believe it.
It's really great.
So is there a resume that I need to give you?
If I want to apply for a job here,
maybe I could play pool all day.
I don't know.
Anyway,
thank you.
It's a fun place to be here and it's fun and thank you to have you here,
but barn partly being here with you,
I can finally see some of the faces behind the news and the entertainment and
the information that the world has come to rely upon.
And now that I see you,
I want to say thank you for all that you are doing.
You are fantastic.
Thank you very much.
Well,
I know that you're anxious to have me talk about my book,
that book that is called,
I'll scream later and some of you may wonder where that title came from.
Well,
I have to admit that if you didn't know already,
I am a recovering drug addict and today it's been 23 years,
two months and 20 days.
And just
thank you.
And just after I won the Golden Globe for best actress in children of a Lesser
God,
I checked myself into Rehab at the Betty Ford Clinic.
Unlike today where my entire journey would have been covered by TMZ and Perez
Hilton back then.
Way back then,
there was no such thing as uh,
being able to w there was no such thing as those things.
So I was able to check it in secret.
And while I was there,
I was nominated for an academy award for best actress.
So if you can imagine,
I must be the only person to get that.
Congratulations.
You've been nominated call while working on my sobriety at the Betty Ford
Clinic.
So anyway,
when the phone call came in from Jack here,
uh,
who by the way,
this is Jack.
Jason,
my interpreter.
If I didn't introduce them already,
sorry,
I don't have a male voice.
I just wanted to let you know that.
Well maybe after a couple of cigarettes.
No.
Anyway,
anyway,
um,
he asked me for a reaction or a statement which wasn't going to be staying
sober.
No,
thank you for the nomination,
but I'm staying sober.
I'm keeping sober.
No,
I didn't want to say that.
So instead I said,
tell them I'll scream later.
And that phrase stuck with me ever since.
And I think it strikes the right tone of humor and irony coming from this death
gal because as you'll see in my book,
I may be death,
but I'm probably one of the loudest people you'll ever meet.
My good friend and mentor,
Henry Winkler put it perfectly when he told me if you will,
it,
it is not a dream for me if you will.
It,
it is not a dream.
It's about intention.
And for me,
even though I was different than everyone else,
I had the will and the desire to make something happen for myself and everything
else just followed.
But Times have changed though.
Today I'm an actress and a film producer as well as an advocate for children's
and disability related causes and most recently a dancer on dancing with the
stars.
I hope you voted for me.
Did you vote okay.
I'm also a mother of four and as a result I'm a cook and a car pool driver and a
room mother and a conflict mediator and a closet organizer and a pretend math
wiz.
Seriously,
life is good.
It's been 23 years since critics said that I won my academy award out of pity
and that I would never work in Hollywood again,
simply because I was deaf and I'm still here.
The barriers that many had predicted would stop my career dead in its tracks
have virtually vanished.
Thanks to many working actors like me who are deaf or differently abled
attitudes have changed now.
Most of the barriers I face are more humorous than they are distressing and here
are a couple of examples because once when I was working on a television show
with Mark Harmon called reasonable doubts,
many of you are probably too young to even know this program was on the air.
But anyway,
once I'll work in the program,
an NBC executive came to visit the studio when we were shooting the show and
after watching me work for a little while he said to the executive producer of
the show,
you know that Marlee Matlin is great,
she's great.
Is she going to be death for the whole show?
Yeah,
it's okay.
I'm over it.
And once while I was ready to appear live on CNN in front of millions of
viewers,
as you know,
CNN has,
the director was counting down the seconds before we were live on the air and I
was getting my makeup,
my last looks and Jack was sitting with the reporter on the other side of the
camera.
As we were counting down with just three seconds,
she leaned over to Jack and said,
could you tell Marley that my dog is death just like her?
And suddenly I was live on television and I'm thinking,
what does she want me to,
did you want to throw me a bone?
Does she want me to say Wolf?
I Dunno.
Okay.
And this thing doesn't only happen in Hollywood,
it happened to me a couple of times.
I don't know about you,
those people who are deaf,
but I'm on a plane ready for the plane to take off.
I'm set my seatbelt design and Jack and I are signing to each other.
The flight attendant comes over,
sees me signing waves,
gives me a menu.
As soon as she sees me signing,
she grabs him and you out of my hand goes to the Galley and returns back with a
new menu in Braille.
Yup.
Actually they have to think about it for a moment too.
And she's like,
yeah,
so what's wrong?
I mean,
you don't,
you need the Braille.
And I'm like,
uh,
no,
I'm def not blind.
And then she realizes it.
And then I never see it for the rest of the flight.
I use these stories not to trivialize the barriers facing people like myself
because every day there is still discrimination against differently abled people
and people who are deaf and whether being in front of the camera,
out and about being a mom or working on behalf of some of my favorite charities.
My message has always been the same and one that I got from my parents that no
matter what abilities we possess,
all of us not only deserve respect,
we deserve to be heard.
In my book,
I chronicle that it wasn't always easy that sometimes I was made fun of out
there and sometimes I fell,
but it was all a part of growing up.
Just because I was deaf,
my parents felt that I should not live a sheltered life.
And far from it,
they believed that it was important for me to embrace life,
both the good and the bad.
So even though I danced in front of 25 million people each week on dancing with
the stars or stood my ground as strong characters who just happened to be deaf
on shows like the l word and on the West Wing,
I still have days when I feel like I'm going out that front door of my parents'
house for the first time to prove that I can do anything except here and
oftentimes I still find myself explaining that yes,
I do drive a car and yes I can have children and yes,
I am a working actress.
Well,
fortunately with your commitment here today to creating greater accessibility,
you at Google have demonstrated that you get it,
you get it.
Because what you're doing here today with youtube and automatic captioning is
nothing short of extraordinary.
I cannot tell you how much I've come to rely on the Internet for my
communication needs
and many others out there.
Many millions of others out there.
I'm sure you've probably heard of the irony of the invention of the telephone,
that when Alexander Graham Bell,
who had a deaf wife and a deaf mother wanted to find a way to help them
communicate.
He thought of the television,
excuse me,
the telephone as a tool that would help them,
but little did he realize that the telephone would be one of the greatest
barriers when it came to communication between the deaf and the hearing world.
Right there.
20 years ago I lobbied and I succeeded in getting the film,
which inspired me to be an actress,
the wizard of Oz,
to be closed captioned for the first time because captioning was crucial in
bringing the words that you all take for granted to my world.
And the following year in 1990 I took it one step further and I went to Capitol
Hill to lobby on behalf of the legislation that all televisions 13 inches or
larger,
she'd be equipped with closed captioning technology
like the critics who doubted my ability to be an actor because in their eyes,
my deafness put me on a level below my peers.
TV and programmers thought that millions of Americans who are deaf or hard of
hearing didn't deserve equal access through closed captioning.
But with the hard work and determination we were successful in getting the
decoder act.
Bill passed six years later and legislation was passed that required that all
broadcast television be 100% closed captioned.
But like the irony of the invention of the telephone,
the Internet eventually became a bigger barrier than one could ever imagine when
it came to closed captioning content on broadband.
Here's a good example.
Just last October,
the wizard of Oz celebrated a wonderful minds,
a milestone,
the 75th anniversary of its initial release,
and for the first time in broadcast history,
it was going to be streamed live to every single American who had access to a
computer for free.
So free,
free,
absolutely free.
So I was eager to share the film with my children,
particularly my then five year old daughter,
in whose eyes I saw the same sense of wonderment and excitement that I had when
I was seven watching the film for the first time about the young girl with the
Ruby slippers,
who dreamt of someplace over the rainbow.
But when I opened up my laptop and hit the play button,
I was horrified to find that the film that I had lobbied to get closed captioned
20 years earlier was shown without captions.
I was told that the technology was not out there and that I had to be patient
and to wait.
Well,
as I said,
I like to make noise.
So I tweeted like crazy to the thousands of followers that I had on Twitter and
I made sure that my friends like Ashton Kutcher and Alyssa Milano knew what was
going on
and what was going on with closed captioning on the Internet and I encourage
them to retweet and they did.
Then I found out there was actually no problem with the technology and in fact
the technology is out there to stream content with closed captions.
When it came down to the same issue,
a lack of understanding,
it was a lack of understanding at that a large percentage of manufacturers said
that we've said that you need to provide access for the millions of viewers who
are deaf or hard of hearing,
so by providing close caption they can get access.
More importantly,
they fail to understand that original programming had captions,
but that the Internet had to have the captions as well.
Eventually the frustration increased so much because I had to fight to make 20
to do what I did 20 years ago all over again.
The ultimate irony came during the unveiling of the celebration of Helen
Keller's life.
There was a statue being unveiled in the Capitol Rotunda and it was streamed
live without captions.
Here we're celebrating and honoring a woman who fought for equality and
accessibility over a hundred years ago and who I looked up to as a role model
and I wasn't even able to share the celebration of her life.
It was simply unacceptable,
unacceptable,
but you at Google,
you changed all that just as you did when you pioneered the search engine.
You are helping to ensure the commitment and standards and legislation that we
worked for accessing broadcast TV are continuing here with your efforts and
getting hundreds and thousands of videos on youtube broadcasts with closed
captions.
So today I am proud to premiere the pilot episode of a show that I produced,
which I hope will become a series,
either a network or web.
It's called my deaf family and the show chronicles a family from right here in
the San Francisco Bay area that is made up of both deaf and hearing family
members.
It's told from the perspective of 15 year old Jared fertile who is hearing
Jareds parents are deaf and they work nearby here at the California School for
the deaf in Fremont and Jared also has three siblings,
two of whom are deaf and one who is hearing.
I like to think of it as a diversion of a little people,
big world and I even pitched it to Tlc in the hopes of creating the first
reality show of its kind ever showing what life is like for millions of
Americans who are deaf and hard of hearing.
Unfortunately,
TLC seemed more interested in doing a show about killing um,
Moose with Sarah Pailin.
So fine.
That's okay.
That's all right.
If TLC won't have me,
I figured I'll do it.
My words and using miss [inaudible] words,
I'm going to go rogue and broadcast it on Youtube where I can call the shots and
where I can get guaranteed that the show will be broadcast with captions.
Thank you Google for making this happen.
I also wanted to say that though I may be deaf,
silence is the last thing the world will ever hear from me.
And that the real handicap of deafness does not lie in the ear.
It lies in the mind.
Thank you for your commitment to breaking through the barriers and providing
access to youtube through automatic captioning.
Through your example,
you're helping to open the minds of those who choose to handicap millions of
people like myself who are deaf or hard of hearing and who don't provide closed
captioning content through broadband.
Your efforts today,
we'll guarantee the hard fought victory we won so many years ago can move
forward into the 21st century.
So without any delay,
please enjoy the premiere of my deaf family on Youtube.
But before I say this,
hold on one second.
I want to introduce to you one of the stars of my deaf family of this program.
Bruschetta born fertile is here with us today.
Could you please stand up?
Okay.
Thank you for coming out.
Taking time out of your busy schedule to be with that.
So I want to thank the children and the students from the California School for
the deaf where we are with us today,
who came out today with us.
So,
uh,
just two things.
Enjoy the show.
Uh,
and I'm going to think about where to find my glasses so I can read it some
more.
Okay,
let's go.
My name is Jared and I'm 15 and I have a family of six.
My Dad's name is Leslie.
The mom's name's Projeta have younger brother.
His name is gay.
I have a little sister named Sabrina.
Youngest brother is alive
and this is my deaf family.
So there you go.
There you go.
This was something that we had been hoping for a long time and now we have the
opportunity to put it there on Youtube.
And we hope that millions of people worldwide,
we have the chance to see this.
And this makes it even bigger than just the pilot.
And thank you.
Brigida.
Thank you Virginia for letting us come into your home for letting us into your
home.
And this was shot Justin.
One and a half days.
That's all we had.
Just one and a half days to shoot.
And Eh,
you know,
it's almost unheard of in the reality programming business to make a pilot that
only covers one and a half days of a family's life.
But I'm very proud of it and I hope that you all enjoyed it.
And I think that we also might be having some.
Um,
do I need to give you the microphone?
We have question and answers or what?
Yeah.
So,
um,
I'm going to ask a few questions and then I'd really like to open it up to the
audience and I'll just start by saying that you're such an inspiration and that
your story is fantastic and wonderful and thank you for coming and sharing.
And,
um,
again,
it really is a commitment of ours as a company to make information accessible.
So I'm so pleased that you can be here and we can share that common goal.
Thank you.
Um,
so I'll start with,
given that we have people in the company here who are,
um,
probably engineers,
probably sales people across the company and they're all people who can work on
some of the accessibility,
what are some of the things that you would like to see us doing on the Internet?
Um,
and how can we make the captioning even better?
Well,
uh,
I mean,
first of all,
if you could make all the captions purple with the Yellow Background.
No,
I'm just joking.
Or a different font.
Perhaps we could go to Helvetica or something and whatever.
No.
Do they have that?
Yeah.
Do you have the ability to change the font?
You do.
You can't change the font.
Oh,
Ooh,
I like that.
That answered my question right away.
Um,
listen,
you're doing it.
You are doing it already.
You're,
you're doing it all.
I applaud you all for what you've done so far.
I don't think there's really any move.
I don't know what more I could ask for.
I know that you can't do it immediately,
perfectly in terms of automatic captioning,
so that it,
the voice recognition works,
uh,
you know,
100% and there might be some confusion.
It takes time.
It certainly takes time,
but you're putting it out there and,
and you know,
we'll,
there's room to make it perfect.
I'll be patient.
Great.
Well,
we'll definitely be working on it.
Um,
I looked at some last night and I'm like,
I noticed that sometimes when people put them on manually,
you can't always tell who is speaking.
Um,
for example,
that like,
I like watched your interview on Larry King and I didn't know when it was,
like if I didn't hear it,
it wouldn't have been always possible to know when you are speaking versus when
your Larry King or the interviewer was speaking.
So I thought like that would be one example is that we actually always have
connotation of who is the speaker.
Um,
for example,
well,
you know,
listen,
when,
when captions first came out,
um,
on television,
uh,
it,
you know,
it was like three's company was the first show that had captions.
I was just fascinated with the fact that there were words on the screen.
I mean,
it was a dream that we had.
it would be great to think about having words way back then and now it's a
reality.
But when they first came out,
um,
it took a little bit of,
of getting used to and adjustment to know who was talking and to be able to
understand,
but then eventually,
um,
they made adjustments so that they had one person speaking on one side of the
screen and one person speaking on the other side of the screen with the
captions.
So it's just a matter of time,
it's,
I wouldn't like it if they put two different colors on there as they do in some
countries with captions.
I think it's too confusing,
I think gets too confusing.
I mean,
I personally don't care for that kind of of,
so.
Okay.
Great.
Um,
so last one more question and then I'd love to hear from the audience here.
but what kind of,
is there any legislation or any,
um,
ways that we could work with policy?
Um,
meaning Google the company,
there's a,
there's a law called HR three one oh one,
excuse me,
I didn't mean to interrupt.
Um,
but,
uh,
she knows,
so HR 301 is out there up on the hill that we want it to get past.
So that would allow for that accessibility in the Internet as we were talking
about today.
It's just not been passed yet.
Okay.
Can you say a little bit about what it is?
Just so everyone here knows?
Well,
Jack Jack could do that better than I did.
Um,
uh,
it's basically yes,
it's basically,
um,
as Marlys said in back in 1990 and then again in 1994,
legislation was passed that required broadcasters to close caption because they
wouldn't do it themselves.
Now with everything moving to the Internet,
it seems that the information that's there captioned isn't moving with captions
and they're still not captioning it there.
So HR 301 is intended to force internet providers to caption what's already been
captured.
So it's applying that law to the Internet and there's a lot of complaints.
Well,
a lot of it is user generated.
We can't caption that.
How are you going to force us to do that?
I mean,
a lot of stuff on youtube is,
is made by people who go to youtube while you guys solve that problem with
automatic captions.
Now it's time for the other people to do that.
So that's what HR three,
one one is intended to do.
And we're waiting for the vote or at least to be even brought up.
I'm not familiar with the legislative process,
but we're waiting for sponsors and the health care bill took up a lot of,
of attention and everybody was focused on that.
So now hopefully we can move to this.
And I've been working very closely with the National Association of the deaf and
hoping that their efforts,
I mean in their terms,
I'm their spokesperson when it comes for closed captioning and hopefully we can
work together to make sure that this legislation pass.
Great.
Well what questions people want to come to the audience.
I come to the other hand that the mic over.
Um,
a special question for you by colleague is actually blind and we've just watched
your reality TV and there are certain points where the texts appeared,
but there was no audio so she couldn't actually hear what was going on.
So it'd be really cool if you could find a way to make that happen.
Well I understand and I believe that they're working on that audio description
technology for people who have low vision or visually impaired.
Um,
people who can hear their sure.
Certainly needs to have some sort of,
uh,
of description,
audio description on the screen.
Um,
I believe that they're working on that here and I'll bring up a Naomi to explain
that
this is the perfect opportunity for me to put in a plug for the access Enj team.
We have a headcount in our team and if you would like to come and help us work
on these problems,
we have a list of really interesting problems we're working on right now.
Um,
there are ways of doing audio description in youtube right now.
You do it by mixing in the audio,
so it's called open audio.
And um,
if anybody is curious,
I uh,
I can send out an email maybe through the author's team list that includes some
lists,
some links to videos that have that.
Um,
so,
uh,
I'm going to hand this back to somebody before I babble too much.
No,
no,
absolutely.
Naomi,
it's important.
Great.
Other other questions?
Sure.
You guys can also stand up at the mic there.
Hi.
A couple of comments and no question,
uh,
first,
for making the captioning technologies that Google,
uh,
become a possibility.
Uh,
we,
there is one person I would like to recognize that my good friend Ken Harris
thing sitting right there,
I was planning to do that.
Yes,
Ken heroin scene.
It,
he has been pushing tirelessly for this to happen in the past few years and he
happened to be my first office made when he joined Google seven years in two
weeks ago.
And my other office may was Greg badge.
I was who it was harder hearing and I was designing servers.
I had this big loud machines in my room and I had the perfect roommates.
They didn't remind.
So,
and uh,
uh,
piece of question is a,
I'm an engineer.
So I was curious like,
why are we hearing people in a room,
one to attract attention?
We usually use the glass or some seem to make a noise.
So everybody took a track.
Everyone's attention.
Uh,
I wonder if,
uh,
for people who don't hear,
how do you do that already?
But
no,
we actually,
we flashed the lights.
We just flick the lights off and on.
Okay.
Or we wave.
But that's it because that's very visible.
I mean,
I could see it because my peripheral vision is very good.
my eyes are the means of which I depend on to use.
Just as you depend on your ears to hear and you can hear anything.
So I'm very visual and if you do this or if you do this,
um,
like when there's Paparazzi for example,
here's a good example.
When I go to Paparazzi,
they're very smart.
You know,
at first when I came into the business,
they would scout my name,
Marley,
Marlene.
Of course,
I would just stand there like,
what are they,
you know,
will be Goldberg,
said,
hey guys,
she's deaf.
You can't yell at a deaf woman.
And then of course then they came up with something.
They do this,
they just make up,
they do pretend sign language.
And then I would look and then they take my picture and they do some more
pretend sign language and then you look and it take my picture and then they've
learned this.
They still do this to this day.
It works.
It works for me.
So I mean for you to get the attention of someone who's deaf and who can't hear
you just do this or are you just tap their shoulder or I mean anything that
involves hand movement or flashing the life off and on from across the room that
usually works or throw something.
Okay,
well,
you know,
spit,
spit ball that way.
Then one suggestion,
and this is more for can actually,
uh,
you're talking about like,
oh,
when you have caching captions,
you sometimes you can read a tale who,
which one on scoring is talking and it seems we have this automatic captioning
technology mostly related to a voice recognition.
We can probably also recognize the tone in the voice,
like the pitch in a voice to tell whether it's male or female or other,
uh,
traits,
all the,
the actors.
Then,
uh,
as we say it,
you say,
I already a weekend fund,
we can put different,
I'd be really,
really curious to see that.
I'd be really curious to see how we can use the softer foam.
Quaintly it's a softer voice and use a square.
Found the way it's a strong voice for example.
Hmm.
Go for it.
What are you waiting for?
Okay,
great.
Thank you.
Thank you for your comments.
Yeah.
Um,
uh,
I'm uh,
I'm a father of five years old,
blind son.
So if you were actually back to five years or oh,
what do you want to ask your parents?
What do you want from them?
Mostly or,
I'm sorry,
English is my second language,
so I
mine too.
I mean I think if if I were in your child's shoes.
Yep.
A five years old,
back five years old,
if you are,
um,
what I would want from my parents.
Yes.
I would say or ask for that.
You take good care of me,
that you don't deny me anything and that you let me be who I am.
Don't try to restrain me from any experiences in life.
Let me go out there,
explore the world.
Let me feel,
let me touch,
let me meet.
Treat me as if I could see.
Okay.
Thank you.
Actually the caption is very helpful for me to understand the English,
so
I'm kind of saying it.
You go thank you very much for your comment.
Thank you.
Hi.
Thank you very much for coming here.
Um,
one of the things I find challenging about using video and audio content is how
long it takes to get the information from it compared with reading written
content.
And I was wondering whether there's anything that you've been thinking about or
working for to enable basically the faster playing of captions or uh,
foster getting them information from video content
and audio content.
I'm going to give your question to can because he's more adept at answering that
question perhaps.
Okay.
He said the answer is yes.
The answer is yes.
We are working on it.
We've got that going now for businesses.
Google video,
Google Biz
video for business.
Do you want to explain some Naomi?
Okay.
So if you guys look at our internal videos on Google video for business,
you can see now there's a little slider that has a rabbit and a turtle on it.
And if you slide it up to the rabbit and it goes faster.
And um,
this is actually worked on by Daniel Steinberg is pretty amazing.
If,
uh,
if you just speed it up audio,
normally it would eat,
the pitch would be really high.
It sounded like the lecture was being given by chipmunks.
So we actually changed the pitch.
So it sounds sort of kind of normal.
And I turned that off because it annoys me.
Even though we changed the pitch,
I just watched the caption.
So if you look at our internal videos,
um,
from like our all hands meetings,
you can see those with captions and you can watch them at two and a half times
the speed.
And this isn't just an internal Google thing.
Um,
anybody who has Google apps has access to this technology.
If they turn it on,
well,
that is so out of my world,
I can,
so I'm amazed.
I'm still amazed,
but I'm learning.
I'm learning.
So we have one comment here.
Uh,
Jaxa you wanted to just come in
of the light setup.
So just to give a background,
I'm blind myself.
Um,
I mean just to add to that,
one thing I would definitely like to tell you is don't treat your kid any
different.
Trust me,
if you let it,
let him or her go,
they will reach the extreme staff will surprise you.
Don't treat them any,
any,
any different at all.
Because as I see a disability is everybody has,
every human being has a limitation.
A blind person just has a limitation of not being,
not being able to see,
but trust me,
they can use the other senses to reach the sky.
So just let them go.
Let them achieve anything and everything that they want that is going to be the
most,
most important thing for them in their life.
Thank you.
Uh,
just just following up to your comment,
thank you very much for your kind of,
by the way,
just as you said,
um,
you know,
all a blind person can't do is to see and all a deaf person can't do is here,
but otherwise it's all there available.
Um,
I need to ask one question before you do.
Well,
you don't,
you know,
go ahead.
Go ahead with your question first.
Go ahead.
Yeah.
Actually,
I have a question just from a deaf person's perspective here,
who's working at Google?
Um,
you know,
I been here,
starting as a young person and even now I've seen many challenges and seen how
things have changed over the years with captions on Youtube now and with your
present to date Taishan today,
I'm wondering if you want to see more captions for deaf people,
um,
like in the future,
in 10 or so or so years from now,
what is it that you're looking for and ways that we can help deaf people more?
Oh,
I get this question every day because it's an actor.
I mean,
in reality,
and I speak on behalf of all actors.
I mean,
only 3% of actors work.
You know,
people who were in the actor's union,
only three,
three of 3% of us work.
And it's hard to find jobs,
uh,
regardless of whether one is deaf or hearing.
But if you're talking specifically about deaf actors,
I think it's probably harder.
I still struggle myself,
believe it or not,
I still struggle as I stand here today.
I had to put up my video in order to sell it,
in order to get people to pay attention to it,
to see how it would go.
A lot of deaf children come up to me and say,
I want to be an actor like you.
How is it that I can do it like you did it?
Or how is it?
And I say,
look,
first of all,
you need to finish school.
If you want to go to college,
go to college.
And it will certainly do you wealth in terms of your future.
Okay.
And then see what it leads you to wherever you want to be.
I'm not the president of the deaf world,
I'm just an actor who just wants to do movies.
And I'm a person who also happens to advocate on,
uh,
on behalf of a number of charities,
charities that I believe in,
charities that I believe need assistance or attention.
And I struggle.
Sometimes I succeed and sometimes I fail.
But you know what?
I get back up on my feet again and I try and I do what I can to find work.
And it's just a matter,
I mean,
there are wonderful deaf theaters out there,
for example,
in Los Angeles as well,
as well as the national theater of the deaf,
wherever you are in the country,
there are places where deaf people can go to school colleges.
There are so many choices out there.
And as much as I would love to be able to own a studio like Warner brothers,
to make sure that everything is captured and say anybody can,
can have access,
it doesn't work that way.
It doesn't work that way.
So,
uh,
oh,
by the way,
my name sign is this.
There you go.
All right.
I guess that's it.
How about last comment?
Uh,
yeah,
just one story that I remember hearing when I was younger was I went to go hear
Vint cerf who is one of the founders of the Internet protocol that we all use
today,
TCP,
uh,
at George Mason University.
He spoke about his wife who was deaf,
but she got a cochlear implant and the invention of the cochlear implant,
they learned about on the Internet while they were browsing around on mosaic web
browser,
which is also very old.
Uh,
but,
uh,
and,
and this is just an amazing thing to me to see,
uh,
just the way that these technologies impact our lives.
It's amazing.
Thank you.
Thank you for your story.
It's see how,
how technology has changed people's lives and people are more accepting of
others who are different and working together and making things happen.
It's amazing.
Last comment.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Um,
that was very inspiring.
just,
I've always loved traveling and sharing culture,
so I thought there was a wonderful opportunity to share some culture,
cultural learnings here.
Um,
so,
um,
I learned from a friend long time ago at that signing applies as this.
So I thought it might be for other people who in the room who didn't know.
I thought it might be interesting for us is to share.
They applies.
Can everyone,
can everyone say thank you?
And I'd like to say thank you to Marley so much for coming,
and I'd like to say thank you for the teams at Google that work on accessibility
and for leading that and for making this happen,
it shows what a big impact you can have and how you can use technology to make
people who you never meet.
People across the world make their lives better.
So thank you.
Thank you for making this all happen.
Thank you Google for making me find my recipes.
Looking for recipe so much easier.
Great.